شدد العاهل الاردنيه الملك عبد الله
الثاني خلال لقاء جمعه في عمان برايس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيمنتنياهو على ضروره
احترام الوضع التاريخي والقانوني للحرم
القدسي الشريف
الامن القومي الامريكي جاكسون في المنطقه
والملتقى فيها نتنياهو وقاده السلطه
الفلسطينيه تمهيدا لزياره المرتقبه لوزير
الخارجيه الامريكي
[موسيقى]
وخارجيه يحاول ترويج لاولويه حكومته
رغمتها
واين هي تحركاته والمواقف الامريكيه من
سعى اداره باهدا لتلاف التصعيد في المنطقه
وما مدى قدرتها على الافاء بذلك الهدف
بالنظر لتركيبه واجله حكومه موريتانيا
والى اين تسير الاوضاع في المنطقه من نظر
الى تمسك بكثير باقتحام الاقصى مجددا وفي
انتظار زياره المرتقبه لوزير الخارج
الامريكي انسانيكان الى المنطقه
[موسيقى]
لم تقدر تمضي اذا الساعات على ما نقلت
وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه عن تعهد
الاردني الملك عبد الله الثاني بعدم
المساس بالوضع القانوني والتاريخي للحرم
القدسي حتى جاءت الاخبار
عناصر من الشرطه والمخابرات الاسرائيليه
باحات المسجد الاقصى ناقله عن وزير الامن
اعتمر بن جبير تاكيده ان اقتحامات تلك
المباحات لن تتوقف
تصريح
اليها خطط لبناء في الوحدات السكنيه
تعتزم حكومه اليمنيه تنفيذها قريبا ليفرض
كل ذلك السؤال عن واقعي وما الات الجهود
الامريكيه الراميه لتهدئه واعاده حل
دولتين الى الواجهه معززا
بمواقفه اقليميه ودوليه تشد من اجره
مشهد جددت الاداره الامريكيه ازاءه دعوه
اسرائيل عن التراجع عن اي اجراءات احاديه
من شانها تقويض حل دولتين وذلك على اعتبره
لوزير الخارجيه الامريكي الى المنطقه ما
حدا لها مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي
جاكسون بزياره التقى فيها قاده اسرائيل
والسلطه الفلسطينيه ليطلق تحذيرات عن
عواقب تقويض حل لدولتين
[موسيقى]
والمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
القدس
الاسرائيليه السابقه
الينا لاحقا ايضا ضيفنا سمير الحباشنه
والسفير مارتن عندك ولكن لنبدا بالضيف
الاسرائيلي
نرحب بكم نبدا بالسؤال يعني اول سؤال ما
الذي حمله معه
وما الذي ذهب به الى هذا اللقاء مع العاهل
الاردني وما الجديد الذي طرحه في هذا
اللقاء برايك
ايه مفيش شك ان هذه الزياره على جانب كبير
من الاهميه خاصه في فتره كانن نوع من
الفطور في العلاقات بين الجانبين
الاسرائيلي والاردني وتحديدا رئيس الوزراء
نتنياه والعاه الاردني هذه زياره تمت
بالتنسيق مع الاداره الامريكيه مع زياره
مستشار الامن القومي
الهدف منها طبعا تهدئه الاوضاع
عشيه او مع حلول شهر رمضان المبارك
ومنعه وحدوث اي نوع من الاحداث في المنطقه
على خلفيه الوضع يعني الشائك والحساس الذي
يتعلق بالحرم القدسي اا تاكيد همم رئيس
الوزراء نتنياهو وليس المره الاولى عده
مراته واكد مرارا وتكرارا على انه لن يكون
هناك اي تغيير على الوضع القائم في القدس
وتحديد ايضا مهام الاردن همم كراعي
الاماكن المقدسه و
ال الوقف الاسلامي الذي يتعلق بالاقصى
لا شك ان هذه الامور تم تحديدها وفقا
يعني كرعايه المملكه الاردنيه
للحرم القدسي ويتم بخلالها السماح
بالزيارات لغير المسلمين ولكن بشرط عدم
اداء اي صلاه ولكن الذي شاهد
وما يحصل على ارض الواقع في وادي اخر يعني
ساعات قليله فقط بعد اللقاء همم جاءت
اخبار تؤكد اقتحام عناصر من الشرطه
والمخابرات الاسرائيليه للباحث المسجد
الاقصى وجاء ايضا كلام او تصريحات بين
كثير عن انه لن يتوقف على الاطلاق عن
اقتحاماته للمسجد الاقصى كيف نفهم هذه
المفارقه ايضا
مفيش شك ان هذه هي معضله كبرى بتتعلق بهذه
الحكومه وان كانت حكومه يمنيه متطرفه ولكن
هي تضم ايضا اللكود واللكود هو ليس حزبا
متطرفا صحيح انه حزب يميني ولكنه هو يعني
يتعلق بنوع من الليبراليه
ويجب ان لا ننسى ان منحم بيجن زعيم اليهود
هو الذي وقع على معاهده السلام مع مصر
والذي وصل ايضا الاتفاق اطار ومفاوضات حول
اطار الحكم الذاتي فهذه الفئه التي دخلت
في هذه الحكومه وفي هذه التركيبه لها
اجنده وانا اعتقد ان هي لن تتوقف عن
المطالبه باجندتها السياسيه وستشك العب ان
على هذه الحكومه وعيب انا على نتانيه الذي
وضع همم يعني عده مهام لهذه الحكومه اولا
تتعلق بجراند توسيعه
من محتوا من معنى عندما يقول سنحترم الوضع
التاريخي والقانوني للحرم القدسي بينما
الوضع على ارض الواقع يقول شيئا اخر بينما
هو يواجه الضغوط التي تحدثت عنها الان
الضغوط الداخليه وليس فقط على المستوى
السياسي على مستوى الشارع وشاهدنا انتفاضه
انتفاضه غير مسبوقه مظاهرات غير مسبوقه في
الشارع الاسرائيلي وتصريحات السياسيه ربما
يهود باراك وهو رئيس حكومه سابق يقول لانه
يدعو لاول مره في تاريخ اسرائيل العصيان
مدني في اسرائيل ما هي خيارات نتانيا
وماخي هي خيارات هذه الحكومه ايضا نعم
نعم الخيار هو صعب جدا احنا نرى ان هذه
الحكومه التي لم يمضي عليها اقل من شهر
واذا بازمات سياسيه يعني تحيط بها واا
وهذا يدفع على الاعتقاد بان يعني هذه ربما
ان هذه الحكومه لن تصدق في وجه التحديات
التي تواجهها اولا فيما يتعلق بالمظاهرات
التي تتزايد للاسبوع وتتصاعد الاسبوع
الثالث على التوالي ضد السياسه المعلنه
بالاصلاحات على الجهاز القضائي ثانيا قالت
وزير في الحكومه الاسرائيليه بامر المحكمه
العليا وهمم ويشكل ركنا اساسيا من اركان
هذه الحكومه ممثلا في هذه الدرعيه النوع
التالي تحدثت عنه هو الاستقطاب داخل
الحكومه بان حكومه بتجمع هذه القوه
اليمنيه المتطرفه ممثله في حزب الصهيونيه
الدينيه برئاسه همم وهذا
يشكل يعني عائقا لنتنياهو من اجل تحديد
ال- ال-
نعم هذا عائل كبير اماميه كما تقول شكرا
لك مايكوهين همم ينضم الينا في هذا النقاش
الان من عمان سمير الحباشنه وزير الداخليه
الاردني الاسبق ومن نيويورك سفير مارتنر
الامريكيه السابق لعمليات السلام في الشرق
الاوسط اهلا بكم استاذ سمير الحباشني انت
وزير داخليه
الى ما كان همم يتحدث به او يقولوا ما
يركوهن من انه هناك عوائق كثيره امام
نتنياهو الرجل رغم كل تعهداته الشارع يقول
شيئا اخر الامور تسير باتجاه اخر وكيف
يمكن اذا الوثوق في اي تعهدات ياهو اذا
كانت حكومه وهو نفسه كل هذه الضغوط داخليا
وخارجيا
مساء الخير استاذه خديجه
حقيقه
بيذكرني هذا في المثل العربي لا تنظر الى
دموع الصياد بل انظر الى ما تفعل يديه
يعني
عمان لم يذكر
ماذا
الى عمان لم يذكر في بيانه اي شيء عن
موضوع القدس انا او موضوع حل الدولتين
انما ذكرناه يبحث عن علاقه استراتيجيه او
تعميق العلاقه الكلام الجميل المنشد هذا
انا اعتقد
زياره نتنياهو من جانبه هي محاوله لكسر
العزله الداخليه والخارجيه همم التي يعني
يخضع له حكومته سيدتي
الامر داخل فلسطين همم
بانفجار كبير جدا لان لكل فعل رد فعل
اشقاء فلسطينيين انا اعتقد اذا ما بقيوا
بهذا الوضع الضاغط عليهم بمائشتهم بحياتهم
همم
باستمرار الاحتلال
بالتوسع الاستيطان انا بظن اننا امام
انتفاضه ثالثه وانتفاضه ثالثه همم مزيج ما
بين الانتفاضه الاولى السلميه والانتفاضه
الثانيه المسلحه يعني لا يمكن ان يبقى
الوضع ما هو عليه همم الامور في فلسطين
تذهب بسرعه
هي تداعيات خطيره
ومتسارعه يعني الامور اذا لم يتم تدارك
وتدارك تحديدا امريكيا يعني انا حقيقه ومن
التجربه الطويله مع اسرائيل ونحن لدينا
معاهده سلامه احنا ولا شقاء المصريين
والفلسطينيين طوال هذه السنوات
المتعاقبه على قاعده كسب الوقت ان يقولوا
بعضهم كلام ماسول ولكنهم على الارض
المتطرف اليميني واليساري والنصف يمين
والنصف يساري برنامجهم على الارض نفسه
التوسع بالاستيطان قدم الارض ولا يتوقف
هذا الامر اطلاقا مثل سنه 18
18000 مستوطنه اعلن عنها اليوم الخان
الاحمر اليوم يهجر اهلهم ويحاول القضاء
على قرع الشيخ دراع على على على حقيقه في
تطهير عرقي بكل ما تعني الكلمه في فلسطين
ولا يعنينا تلك شعارات الماسوله التي تصدر
بين وقت اواني
الولايات المتحده
كل هذا يصب في مرمى الولايات المتحده
الى السفير مارتن عندك فعلا كل شيء يتحول
الى مرمى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هذه
تداعيات الخطيره التي تحدث عنها الان
الوزير سمير الحباشنه اذا لم تتركها
الولايات المتحده ستزيد خطوره ما الذي
تفعله الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لتدارك
الامر الان قبل ان يزداد خطوره
مساء الخير
بما يحصل في اماكن اخرى في العالم لاسيما
الحارثي اوكرانيا وكذلك صعود الصين
واحد ابرز مخاوفه المتحده بالنسبه الى
وصول حكومه يمنيه متطرفه الى اسرائيل
ومناطق اخرى من العالم وهذا بالتحديد مع
كان في بالي جلاله الملك الاردن حين
استضافه
حول الحفاظ على الوضع الراهن فيما يتعلق
بالحرم القدسي وليس هذا فقط لو ان نتنياهو
يوتيه لاعضاء الحكومه المتطرفين بان
يحققوا ما يريدونه في الضفه الغربيه او في
القدس
فالامور سوف تنفجر وانا اوافق زميلي من
الاردن انا الوضع فعلا يهدد بالانفجار حين
ذلك سوف يكون او سوف يحصل عكس ما تتمناه
الولايات المتحده وتسعى اليه اذا اعتقد
انه في الوقت الحالي فانا اداره الرئيس
بعيدا مستعده
وتترك له مجالا الحركه ولكن هناك نعيدام
الثقه
ولهذا السبب يلتقي مستشاره مع ساليفان ومع
وزير الخارجيه بلين كان في الاسبوع المقبل
في محاوله لتبيان ما اذا كان من الممكن
التعامل معه ولكن طبعا دائما هناك رساله
واحده
صحواها انه لا يجب القيام بما من شانه ان
يعزز الوضع او يزيد الوضع سوءا طيب اضافه
لي ما ذكرته انتروبلين كان من انه
جيكسوليفان ذهب الى المنطقه همم الى
اسرائيل هناك ايضا زياره مرتقبه لوزير
الخارج انتوني بلينكن هناك اهتمام بالوضع
هناك ايضا اجتماع لرؤساء اجهزه المخابرات
او الاستخبارات الاسرائيليه والامريكيه
والمصريه وربما هناك اشياء لا نعلمها لم
يعني
تطفوا الى الى السطح حول ما يجري طبخه او
ال- ال- التجهيز والاعداد له ما الذي يعني
في اي سياق يمكن ان ندرج اجتماع اجهزه
مخابرات الدول الثلاثه اسرائيل امريكا
ومصر
اعتقد ان الاساس هو ما قلته من قبل قد
تبدو الامور مبسط اكثر من اللازم ولكن من
المنظور الامريكي فان التركيب هو تهدئه
الوضع من اجل تعزيز الاستقرار وطبعا مصر
تعتبر اساسيه من ذلك وكذلك الاردن
اياهم هناك عدد من الجهات التي يمكن ان
توضح لنتانيا هو انه اذا ما سماح
للمتطرفين في حكومته بان يفعلوا ما يشاءون
سيكون لذلك تبعت سلبيه نعم
طيب في اي سياق انت تفهم اجتماع رؤساء
اجهزه الاستخبارات في هذه الدول الثلاث
ه الكل يتحدث عنها تحتاج الى وقائع على
ارض الواقع والقصه مش كلام نحن الان امام
شعب يعاني الاستيطان مستمر اخترقات الاقصى
مستمره قهر الشعب الفلسطيني في حياته
وفيما عشت مستمر كيف لنا ان نتحدث عن تهدي
هذا من هذه الوقائع عندما نقول تهديء نريد
فك فكه هذه الوقائع وحلها لغايه حل مرضي
الكل يتبنى اللي هو حل الدوالتين اما ان
نقول تهدى على ماذا يعني حتى موضوع الاقصى
وهو مساله معنويه وبها وصايا اردنيه
وهاشميه حتى هذه المساله لا تسلم من
اليمين ومن المتطرفين صهاينه في فلسطين
الان نتحدث عن تهنئه عندك
في امريكا عندما تريد الولايات المتحده ان
تقرر ان هناك تهدئه في المنطقه عليها ان
تجبر اسرائيل باتخاذ اجراءات ذروه هذه
الاجراءات الجلوس على الطاوله لاقامه
الدولتين وانهاء موضوع الاستيطان وما ينسج
ما قرارات شرعيه الدوليه خلاف ذلك صدقيني
لن تستفيد لا اجتماعات امنيه لانه السيده
خديجه الامن
المجرد
مساله
قابله للكسر الامن المجرد لا يفيد
اجتماعات الامنيه لا تفيد ولا تستطيع خدمه
الامر على الواقع عندما الامور تصل الى حد
المواجهه وحد الانفجار بدنا نتحدث في
مرحله دقيقه جدا في يمين متطرف يحاول على
الارض ان يضع مكانته مثل ما قال من غفير
لسه نتنياهو لازال في الجو عائد الى الى
فلسطين المحتله يقول همم هذه دولتنا دوله
مستقله ولنا الحق ان نعمل بها ماشئنا انا
بظن الامور ليست يا مستر عندك انشغالكم في
مناطق اخرى لا يعني ان تجبروا حليفكم
التاريخي الذي يستقوي على الفلسطينيين
بسلاحكم بل اخوه
وسؤال مباشر
الامريكيه بالسلاح الامريكي يعني المساله
تحتاج حقيقه الى تحرك جدي من الولايات
المتحده طيب
الاستاذ سمير الحباشنه الامر في الوصفه
الواقعيه بعيدا عن الحلول الامنيه هي حل
يقوم على جر اسرائيل وامريكا قادره على
ذلك جرها الى طاوله محادثات مفاوضات
مباشره مع اصحاب الشان مع الفلسطينيين من
اجل حل سياسي دائم
الا تستطيع امريكا ان تفعل ذلك
العزيز من الاردن امرا غير واقعي نحن ندرك
ذلك ولكن يجب ان نعمل عليه ولكن ليس فقط
لدينا حكومه يمنيه متطرفه في اسرائيل تقف
ضد حال الدولتين ولكن ايضا لدينا قياده من
الجانب الفلسطيني
ليست قادره على دخول في مفاوضات ابو مازن
السكس
السياسي ليس هناك بديل الضفه الغربيه وغزه
منقسمه بين فتح وحماس
بناء عليه وبالنظر الى ظروف القائمه في ما
يتعلق بالقياده مينا طرفين
هذا الكلام
يحتاج لرد من سمير الحباشنه انه الحل عند
الفلسطينيين لانهم موسمون لان ابو مازن
راحل لانه ليس هناك بديل لابو مازن
باختصار لو سمحت لانه انتهى وقت البرنامج
يعني سيدتي هذه الاسباب اللي بطرحها دائما
نتنياهو الشعب الفلسطيني حتى حماس وتذكري
بانهم قد وافقوا على حل دولتين هذا متفق
عليه يعني ما يرموا قصه الانقسام
الفلسطيني ك- كاكذريعه سيدتي عندما ارادت
الولايات المتحده ان تقف بكل ثقه ولا وراء
اوكرانيا وقفت عسكريا وسياسيا وهي تقف في
مواجهه روسيا انا اعتقد وانا هذه الكلمه
اخيره الامور اذا لم تتحرك الولايات
المتحده المنطقه جميعا باتجاه الانفجار
شكرا لك لان نتمنى ذلك شكرا جزيلا لك سمير
الحباشنه وزير الداخليه الاسبق شكرا
لحضورك معنا في هذه الحلقه ونشكر ضيفنا من
نيويورك سفير مارتنر الامريكي السابق
لعمليات السلام في الشرق الاوسط شكرا لكم
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر لكم منا اطيب المنى والى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]